خسائر كبيره في الارواح والممتلكات واشخاص
يبيتون في العراء ابرز مخلفات ماساه
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب شمال غرب سوريا
الذي بات يفتقر لابسط مقومات الحياه فبعد
مرور 11 يوما على الكارثه الطبيعيه التي
قلبت حياه المتضررين راسا على عقب كشفت
الاحصائيات الرسميه عن مقتل اكثر من عشره
الاف السوري حتى الان في الزلزال الذي ضرب
البلدين في حين تحدثت وسائل اعلام تركيه
عن مقتل سته الاف وثلاثمائه سوري في تركيا
فقط اكثر من نصفهم دفنوا هناك والباقي تم
ادخالهم عبر المعابر الحدوديه السوريه
التركيه التي تشمل معبر باب الهوى ومعبر
الراعي ومعبره السلامه ويبلغ عددهم
1705 النزوح بات الحل الوحيد بالنسبه
للعشرات من السوريين حيث اكتشفت منظمه
منسق استجابه سوريا ان عدد النازحين جراء
الزلزال بلغ
171,843 شخصا في حصيله غير نهائيه غير ان
كثره اعداد النازحين في شمال غرب سوريا
شكلت صعوبه كبيره في عمليه الاحصاء وفق
منسق الامم المتحده الاقليمي للشؤون
الانسانيه للازمه السوريه
الان ومع تزايد هذا العدد نجد صعوبه كبيره
في تحديد عدد الاشخاص الذين نزحوا مجددا
بسبب الزلزال
على الجانب الاخر النظام السوري وفي اول
رد له حول تداعيات الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا ضرر ضعف الاستجابه بان المرافق
السوريه لم تكن مهيئه للتعامل مع مثل هذه
الكارثه
لان سوريا لم تكن منطقه زلازل مدمره على
امتداد قرنين ونصف
فلا المنشات والابنيه ولا المؤسسات
والمعدات محضره للكوارث الطبيعيه
ومع التطورات الحاصله لا تزال الهزات
الارتداديه تقض مضاجع منكوب الزلزال حيث
استيقظت حلب وجوارها على هزه جديده
تسببت في تضرر مباني ورجفان قلوب تحاول
استعاده رباطه جاشها